hey everybody i'm here once again and we
are waiting for a donald trump press
briefing scheduled
for the bottom of the hour originally
but then it looked like it was kind of
rescheduled to quarter past
and things nobody's in the room yet but
anyway we have a live feed earlier than
we typically do
so maybe i mean we just don't know
um it may be it may not be i would
expect a lot of focus on donald trump's
claiming victory over the normalizing of
relations between israel and the united
arab emirates we're going to talk about
that a little bit later i have a ton
a ton of stuff to play for you from the
standpoint of memes videos
animations and comedy and so we're going
to get to that in a little bit
and i i ended up not putting super chats
up on the screen today's
sort of like my last or second to last
day in the bunker
and with the two monitors normally i
like to have four monitors for my
streams with the two monitors that i
have
it's just difficult to do in a way that
would be
would give me access to all of the stuff
that i need
so we'll be back to super chats on
screen next week but i still
see them for example paul jm just asked
whether i'm finally used to the girth
and width of my new microphone this is
actually the old microphone but the new
one is
is fine um danny thompson says two quick
hits from today's events bad
joe biden looked and sounded really old
today funny
fox did not cut over until kaylee spoke
so they broadcast
zero of kushner's preening remarks
next is the misogynistic man-child yes
the tangerine terror
the mango menace uh
the orange orifice maybe i don't know
that's something
we're gonna be looking at a bunch of
funny stuff momentarily i will have
updates for you about the
um brutal brutal attack
on the david pakman show website that
took yes to a place yesterday during the
live stream i have updates about
what's going on with sam cedar and some
more shots have been fired but yeah
yesterday was a very
uh problematic day from a tech
standpoint that's for sure
um oh i've been muted this entire time
oh my god i've been muted this whole
time again
nobody's been able to hear me
oh my god i can't believe i did it again
this i've been muted this whole time no
i'm kidding i know i know that i wasn't
i know that i wasn't
i people try to trick me into thinking
i'm muted muted when i'm not
okay where where do we even start today
oh i'm coming in a little hot actually
let me back away a little bit from the
mic
okay let's just should we go through
some of the funny things i have i mean i
i want as many people as possible to see
some of these let me do an update first
on
on
the fight for a million we have now
moved up another three days so as of
yesterday we were scheduled to hit a
million
subscribers on youtube on november 22nd
it's now been moved up to november 19
meaning we are only 16 days away
as far as a projection obviously
nothing's guaranteed
16 days away from november 3rd which is
the goal um
and we do have a video that went
sort of like instaviral at 4 pm
um about yesterday's press briefing
actually
in the first wow in the first hour it
already has a hundred and sixty thousand
views that's unbelievable so that'll
probably bring in a few more subscribers
and then hopefully this stream will do
okay so so we're actually you know i got
some funny messages yesterday
um telling me david there are people on
the internet
who are criticizing you saying the only
reason you're
you're accelerating past sam cedar
is that you're doing um uh viral
anti-trump videos and live streams
it's like wait that's like saying you're
only winning the race because you're
running faster than everybody else
what how is that even a criticism yeah
i'm making content
and some of the content does well so
people subscribe it's like it's a
it was a very weird criticism i didn't i
didn't really get it and by the way
um twitch our last 10 days on twitch
have been our best 10 days on twitch
since like the first time i ever did a
stream and we got like
3 000 followers in a day so we're very
much uh
we're very much uh doing the twitch
things all right so let's get let's get
into some of these other things that i
have because i think you're going to
enjoy some of these
um here's a funny edit of what remember
monday when the secret service guy
pulled trump off of the stage this is a
user me
say smart words good on our our
subreddit
here's his uh he was able he found a
different audio feed of the secret
service guy take a listen
jones are going to be i mean the way
they're going
it looks like they're just about going
to be topping records hopefully soon
excuse me sir paula reed is here and
she's going to ask you another nasty
question
uh-oh something's happening they're
pulling trump out
is there some kind of threat all right
so that's pretty good i like that one
that was a good one
um here oh oh this is one of my favorite
things
i've mentioned before when uh people's
pets
like watching the david pakman show
please
film them and send them to me
and i have this great video from about a
year ago of a portuguese
dog not not a portuguese water dog i'm
not talking about the breed portuguese
water dog
i'm talking about an actual dog in
portugal who
seems enraptured by the sound of my
voice and this is another video this
is what's this dog's name hold on a
second
i think this is willow apparently when i
pulled out the old calculator yesterday
during the live stream
willow just could not look away and i
guess she's captivated by the sound of
my voice take a listen to this
[Laughter]
we only have isn't that great i just
love it and it's like it's not even that
the dog
the dog is watching me the dog is
watching me do math
however all right so i believe this dog
is named willow
if you have video of your pets
watching the show please send them to me
through our website contact form uh the
letterhack
who is a great cartoonist put together
this image
about the um fight to a million
with sam cedar let me zoom it out a
little bit
that didn't work that's so weird i
zoomed out and yet it zoomed back in
that's bizarre
how can i do this i don't know why it's
not all showing
um okay well in any case uh left is best
entertainment system console this is a
great video game
all made up and totally joking as i've
mentioned about the fight for a million
with sam cedar it is completely made up
and we are just kidding although we have
to pretend not to it is called beast
mode rampage
their sam now i seem to be a lizard and
sam is muscle bound that's interesting
the competition for most subs between
pac-man
and majority report is getting heated
beautiful art love when
when i see creative stuff like this um
a couple other things this somebody is
calling
patented pacman wisdom let's see what's
up with this
resulted in mortal yosemites are at
particularly high risk of fatalities
if they don't get plasma that's that's
actually good i think that that's
actually a really
really good uh that that actually makes
sense to me let me listen to that again
resulted in more yo semonites are at
particularly high risk of fatalities
if they don't get plasma beautifully
said
beautifully said um and then oh
okay we can i guess do the stuff about
the ddos
attack here's the ddos situation this is
from yesterday's stream as well
those numbers are incredible so we are
actually experiencing a ddos attack
right now we have
three people working on it on our
website and uh clearly somebody not
wanting people to sign up for
memberships a direct attack on the david
pakman show we've dealt with it before
uh we have people working on it but we
are under a ddos attack as we speak
yeah very important disclaimer that i
issued yesterday so um
the bottom now i want to be really clear
i mentioned yesterday that our website
was getting hit with a ddos attack from
two indian ip addresses i'm not saying
indian hackers were were the
perpetrators
all i'm saying is whoever was executing
the ddos
attack by submitting thousands and
thousands of
bogus requests to our website um
was using indian ip addresses it may
have been merely to mask their actual
location so we ended up having to
mobilize
some resources during yesterday's stream
we did eventually get the website back
up and running yesterday
there were it 120 people tried to sign
up for memberships when the website
crashed
only about 30 were actually
able to so it was a bit of a bummer but
i think maybe some of those people will
sign up today
i do want to say thanks to spudnik19 for
gifting
five subscriptions on twitch as well as
thanking
liquid ice for the subscription
raziel vic 412 his right hand
menace dq extra high and
a whole bunch of other really great
people over on youtube a lot
of super chats coming in albex rooney
wants to know whether pets count in the
race to a million subscribers
pets can't consent to contracts and thus
they can't have google accounts meaning
you can't sign up for my youtube channel
pets can't sign up for my youtube
channel unfortunately i want to do it
clean
lee buddy says honestly david knowing
what you know now what would be the top
two questions you'd ask trump in an
interview after his inauguration curious
honestly
i haven't thought about that i mean
there's no way trump would ever consent
to an interview with me
so it's not something that i've thought
about
um wallarizmi wants to know from the
standpoint of future events considering
trump supporters show elements of cult
behavior once their leader is out
how will they influence the republican
party moving forward will they stay
politically involved
i don't pretend to know the answer to
that and i i gave a few of my thoughts
on that last week in terms of whether
the anti-trump
versus the trump pro-trump republican
party separate and how and
how into what degree they remain engaged
after the presidency is over
we're gonna have to wait and see on that
johnny minogue wants to
says hi from a socially distanced m
street beach have you been here before
i've been to m street beach
i've been to uh what's it called
pleasure bay
and uh what every little beach area
there has some kind of uh
name there's a cove and sullivan's
seafood i've been all over
that area yes absolutely um
let's see jhwh said
a sad super chat saying my husband
38 years old with whom i've had a
relationship for 18 years is considering
leaving me 32 years old for a 17 year
old no advice needed just venting
if that's true that sounds difficult
that sounds difficult and i'm
i'm sorry to hear that um
let me say thank you to a few new
members before i forget
noah sauger is new member number one
janet burrell is new member number two
well that was weird i went off screen
cody strickland
is new member number three christian
scardina
is new member number four and bryant
duff
delayon is new member number five today
at joinpakman.com you will notice the
website working
it couldn't be working any better the
website's working beautifully today
okay i have something else very special
for you
which is a delightful animation this is
from a youtuber named
silkworm who has given me permission to
re-upload this to my channel this is
really good
this is a sort of compilation of the
recent
what silkworm did is he wove together
a bunch of different live streams that
i've done to create
this animated narrative this is really
really good i mean this is this is
arguably
well this is in the top five of sort of
like ancillary
content that has been made from david
pakman show content take a look at this
i'll make sure that our volume is up
over here so if trump does start
we won't miss it this is just a couple
minutes
so listen while i have you what what
should i be doing on twitch i'm trying
to
keep growing and revitalizing on twitter
this is definitely don't really
you know i i i'm thinking of what uh i
want the right twitch strategy and you
seem to be a good person to go to for
that
well right now holy [ __ ] david right now
the twitch meta is actually chess
maybe i should run another tournament
would you play in it if i did maybe i'd
consider it you know
right you would consider it yeah i would
i think i would all right yeah
i think next week is going to be chess
on twitch for me right beautiful
and are all 16 players have been
announced right this is hikaru yes they
we yeah i announced them earlier on the
stream most have already been announced
but the last two were announced on
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell the
second would be an interesting player
in the tournament uh yeah i mean you i
like i feel like your
politics and the way you explain things
a little bit better honestly
really oh my god clip that jeez holy
[ __ ] we've got to clip that
that's shocking last thing before we
move on have you taken a position
on the david pakman versus sam cedar
race to a million youtube subscribers or
are you abstaining from that
interesting well i haven't even heard
about this so i don't have a take on it
yet it stirred up the progressive media
space dramatically
my hot take is that if you're botting it
would show in your engagement levels and
it probably isn't
so right all right well good i feel like
i i think i had a cold take though i'm
sorry
okay let's look at a few different uh of
things elements that i have to play for
you
there was a very ugly moment the other
day with stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell ii and one of my
chess coaches alexandra botez
you tell me what you make of this that
this seems like there's a little bit of
i don't know if we would call it
jealousy or envy seems a little weird
take a look at this
but hey listen i hope you have fun i
hope you have fun with your new best
friend david pakman playing in pogchamps
okay i hope you guys uh
have a great time over there and i'll
just be over here getting dumped by my
fiance
you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's pretty
aggressive
um i didn't like i i don't like how
destiny
he seems rattled and until now the one
thing i will say is
my hair is not this color that's the
only thing but but otherwise this is
greatly by the fact that alexander has
been
coaching me it's weird it's weird and
i'm gonna have to probably get a hold of
him and see if we can clear some of that
up because that's a very
i don't want things going in that
direction with stephen right
and you know i i just think we have to
be very very careful there
okay so we've got that other memes i
don't know why
other memes on the screen i find
absolutely hilarious
see if i can put these up on the screen
yeah here we go let me see
there we go so all right so there it is
that the the go check out
the wizard and the slug by silkworm who
did a really really good job with that
and we're going to be posting that to
our youtube channel and i think it could
be
people i think people are going to love
it it's really really well done
and yeah the uh the depiction of my set
is really well done
um you know my shirts are good the
i believe that hikaru is a new character
for silkworm i don't know that hikaru
has been in these before so really
really just such creative
derivative content and i don't know if i
should call it ancillary or derivative
content
but really good stuff very good okay
this press briefing was originally
scheduled for 5
30. it was then rescheduled for 5 15
so i guess maybe once they're late it
will actually be
for 5 30. i don't know the white house
feed is not yet live which is usually a
sign that we're still more more than a
five
five minutes out uh robert olin
has just sent in a 1 000 swedish kroner
super chat which is blowing
all other super chats out of the water
today with the message
sweden sends some swedish capitalism oh
my god
that is a that is a shot across the bow
if i've ever seen one thank you
robert i really appreciate that um
james watson says what do you think
about tulsi hijacking the republican
party in 2024 assuming biden wins
i think nothing of it i just that's not
even interesting to me
unknown prodigy says any strategy for
pog champs you want to reveal
no not really not really still working
on it
chakuseki says what's the likelihood
trump shows up sedated and slurring on
clownazepam and repeats his briefing
three to four times
how what do you guys think was going on
yesterday there was a point at which
uh donald trump re-read three or four
different sections of his press briefing
three or four times and it wasn't clear
whether he meant to it was like it was
on repeat and in fact the recount did an
interesting video let me pull
this up um it wasn't just
our impression that donald trump was
repeating
exactly the same stuff that he had been
saying since
april or may about the virus take a look
at this video that the recount did this
was pretty interesting it's on my show
today
the united states has now conducted more
than
61 million more than any other than any
country in the world
population 1.5 million residents of
nursing homes
about five times about five times that
of other european countries
we're on track this is wild right i mean
this it did
this it's eerie yeah if you see people
in the chat it is bizarre
as soon as the vaccine is exceeded we've
delivered over
1 800 rapid point of care testing
devices
anyway you guys get the idea so it
wasn't just me
metaphorically saying we've heard all of
this stuff before
um we really had we really had and
they're just repeating a lot of that
stuff
uh i see a ton of people saying they
sent that to me and i didn't give them
credit
a ton of people sent it to me a ton of
people sent it to me and i came up with
it on my own
um we do have a um we do have a
swedish uh battle going on right now via
super chat
robert olin sent a thousand swedish
kroner super chat bragging about swedish
capitalism
our friend pair tiran now is in on the
action
with a 500 swedish kroner super chat
saying let's listen to the madness david
i have installed bs
filters on my headphones if the filter
fails will you save
us i will try to a lot of photographs
being taken right now
geez thanks to um
super 60 vox for subscribing with twitch
prime
i appreciate that and let me now
actually thank uh
oh boy kaylee mcinanny
some dude i don't know that's scott
atlas uh
rebecca kelly pie croft is
new member number six today spotty
stripes is new member number seven
james malone is new member number eight
jeff liebrick is new member number nine
this is the time to get them in my
friends join pacman.com
uh thomas paquette is new member number
10
kevin mcdonald is number 11 today wow
eric
azaris is number 12.
who am i missing i think i'm caught up
um the website is back up and running i
know a lot of people were unable to sign
up yesterday
but i i'm sorry our website got hacked
it is back up people were really
some hackers were really committed not
to allow you to sign up yesterday
but you can sign up at joinpakman.com
the coupon code still works everything
still works joinpakman.com 2020 now you
save 66
and um the website could not be
functioning better
we've put in a few new uh protective
elements
and um i think we are we are in pretty
good shape
um people saying that how is that even
possible that my latest youtube video is
down
that doesn't make any sense how how does
youtube go down
um no it seems to be up it has 200
000 views in the first 90 minutes that's
insane
everything seems fine on youtube guys
it's really weird
um okay then what else do we have going
on um i already addressed the fight for
a million subscribers the latest count
is oh here's trump the latest count is
we're at 938 000 that's where we are all
right let's listen and see what we got
today
let's get some volume thank you very
much
it was just uh announced by attorney
general barr
that they've caught the killer
of legend to pharaoh
horribly shot young man wonderful young
man
and we have just
this just came out two minutes ago so
attorney general barr just announced as
you know we
named operation legend after legend to
faro
where we're going to be helping out and
are in the process
of helping out cities throughout our
country that have
difficulty with crime in particular
certain types of crime so that's
really good news they caught the killer
of legend
today we saw joe biden continue to
politicize a
pandemic and to show his appalling lack
of respect for the american people
give me a break at every turn
biden has been wrong about the virus
wrong ignoring the scientific evidence
and putting left-wing politics before
facts and
evidence sleepy joe opposed both the
china and the europe travel bans you
know that he opposed the
china travel ban that i instituted very
early and the europe
travel ban that i instituted quite early
if he had followed if we
went after and listened to his advice
hundreds of thousands more people would
have died
this is according to many people i
believe that
dr fauci agreed with that he said that
president
trump made a great decision when he put
the ban on china
joe biden wants to i have not altered
the color of trump's skin with any kind
of
color balance or anything like that no
this community based on his policies
he wants to have ridiculous
open borders i've been saying from the
first day i
started campaigning for this great
office that
you have open borders you don't have a
country you don't have a country with
open borders
so he wants open borders the democrats
want open borders
just not true and nobody take a look at
our southern border we would have
not even been alluded to the wall is
getting close to
miles long and it's having a huge impact
so we disagree with him on that that's
one of the many different
many things that we disagree with
but while joe biden would allow rioters
and looters and criminals and
millions of illegal aliens to roam free
in our country
he wants the federal government to issue
a sweeping new mandate
to law-abiding citizens he wants the
president of the united states with the
mere stroke of a pen to order over 300
million american citizens to wear a mask
for a minimum of three straight months
i guess this just happened what is he
talking about what
no matter where they live and no matter
their surroundings
because different states are much
different both in terms of the
atmosphere itself and also in terms of
also if that were true and it ended the
pandemic like wouldn't we all just do it
but it's not i've not even seen that
i've not seen biden say that at all
president has to issue such a mandate or
how federal law enforcement could
possibly
enforce it or why we would be stepping
on governors throughout our country many
of whom have done a very good job and
they know what
is needed also many of our
50 states are doing the
[Music]
the job at a level that frankly
people are really surprised including
foreign governments that are calling us
constantly and asking
no for advice so i want to just say our
governor if anybody's asking
for advice it's for what not to do to do
the opposite of what this guy tells them
pence and myself and everybody else
that's been
going we have uh scott now involved and
so scott congratulations but you'll be
working with a lot of governors you've
already scott atlas
and dr fauci and dr burks if the
president has the
unilateral power to order every single
citizen to cover their face in
nearly all instances what other powers
does he have is this another straw man
he
refused biden to take questions he
couldn't answer any of them couldn't
answer the questions he refuses to take
questions he never takes questions i
take questions he never takes questions
and you said trump probably shouldn't be
taking them but they're not that
difficult
some can be nasty but they're not that
difficult
but he never takes questions so he just
i guess left i didn't see it but i guess
he just left the podium
put it in your minds my administration
has a different approach we have urged
americans to wear masks
and i emphasized this is
a patriotic thing to do maybe they're
great
and maybe they're just good maybe
they're not so good
yeah they're bad frankly uh what do you
even if they're bad trump says he has no
idea they might be bad but he's still
suggesting you wear one
we do and we've been saying wear them
when it's appropriate especially in
terms of social distancing if you can't
distance enough
and uh what do you have to lose
but again it's up to the governors like
with hydroxy right we want to have
a certain freedom we want to have a
certain freedom that's what we're about
at the same time we also understand that
each state is different and
is facing unique circumstances you have
very very different
states facing very unique
differences and circumstances we've
entrusted the governors
of each state elected by the people to
develop and enforce their own mass
policies and other policies following
guidance
from the federal government and cdc
what's interesting is that either way
it would be up to the governors to do a
policy on masks the complaint is that
trump didn't early enough urge governors
to put in place guidelines since but we
did not need to
bring the full weight of the federal
government down
on law-abiding americans to accomplish
this goal americans must
have their freedoms and i trust the
american people
and their governors very much i trust
the american people and the governors
want to do the right thing
to make the smart decisions and
joe doesn't joe doesn't joe doesn't know
too much
unlike the biden approach our approach
is guided by science that's why
we're focused on protecting the
high-risk americans that
is why we're delivering effective
medical treatments to dramatically
reduce the
fatality rate and that is why we're
i'm not blurring trump's hair for people
asking if i've put a blur filter on his
hair
time you'll see that i think very soon
sleepy joe rejects the scientific
approach in favor of
locking all americans in their basements
for months on end
which i think is something that scott
would be very opposed to
i think i can speak for you we've been
dealing pretty strongly over the last
number of weeks but he wants them
in the basement for months on end and
you have governors that have been very
very
strict on keeping people in their houses
keeping people
in there wherever they may be apartments
and frankly i don't think the results
are necessarily better than other
results
but he wants to shut down our economy
close our schools
and grind society to a halt
and he wants it done by a federal decree
this would lead to a cripplingly long
long lasting depression this struggling
long-lasting depression and yesterday i
showed you the numbers about how well
we're doing coming back with auto sales
and
auto manufacturing and used car sales
and housing
sales at numbers that nobody would have
believed and we're back and very strong
it's a very strong v it's almost used
carson
straight up v we'll be discussing that
over the next couple of days but the
economy is coming back and
the employment numbers over the last
three months are a record
in history of our country and we'll be
back next year i think we'll be
maybe even stronger than the previous
year where we set
every record in the book on employment
and if he's gone that's fine by the way
our stock market numbers are
very close to record and nasdaq is
actually record over the last 14 days 14
for 14 times
now it's been record 14 and that's
during what we hope will be the more
final stages of the pandemic
so if we did what biden wanted to do it
would shut down our health care system
and lead to a massive increase in
mortality
including suicide overdose heart disease
and countless other physical and mental
harms they're doubling down on suicide
today this guy
charlie kirk who you might be familiar
with said that there would be hundreds
of suicides if we don't have college
football in the fall
now people really like college football
but hundreds of people will kill
themselves if they miss
a few games of watching it on tv that's
weird
through suicide through so many other
things
alcohol drugs biden's approach
is regressive it's anti-scientific and
it's very defeatist but it'd be very bad
for our country
while joe biden has been playing
politics from the sidelines he has no
clue
we've been solving problems and
delivering tremendous results
the most advanced and robust testing
system on the planet
the number one producer of ventilators
in the world by far
unprecedented industrial mobilization
biggest since world war ii operation
warp speed to deliver life-saving
treatments and
very soon a vaccine what a
plan by joe biden has actually laid out
would do
we've really already accomplished in
fact many of the things that was well
reported over the last few days
every single thing he said to do every
single thing we did
and we did them well so bidenism
did biden have the wrong ideas or the
right ones which you did which
is it what he thinks we should do when
he
spews it out and then he i guess you
could say he plagiarizes and he
really did in our case because every
single one of the events
i think hayley we can say that was uh
something we had already done
so we'll defeat the virus but not by
hiding
in our basements he's got to come out of
his basement
we'll defeat this virus through a common
sense mitigation
effort shielding those at highest risk
and
unleashing america's medical and
scientific genius which is what it is
and we've already been doing it and
we're very close to having
something that's going to be very very
special in the form of therapeutics and
vaccines to
joe i would say stop playing politics
with the virus too serious
partisan politics has no place here it's
a
shameful situation for
anybody to try and score political
points while we're working to save lives
and defeat the pandemic
right in times of national challenge
america's
and americans and we are by the way we
are working with countries
from all over the world and they're
trying to learn from us
and some of the countries that you spoke
most well about are having a tremendous
surge right now
but it'll work out but americans must
unite together and they must put
politics aside and have to
the closed captions are actually
hilarious common good
seeing trump transcribed adds to the
crazy
trials are doing really well we're
producing the most
promising vaccine candidates in advance
as you know part of the largest
industrialization ever it's
incredible when i meet with heads of
companies that are doing this
that are the best companies anywhere in
the world uh
it's incredible where they are how
they're doing and the speed
with which they're doing it and also the
speed with which the fda
is approving things because by any other
standard you would have been
two or three years away from being at
the point that we're at
by the end of this week we will have
shipped 1846
rapid point-of-care testing devices to
nursing homes which are
a very important source as you know for
people that are not handling
the plague from china very well
this week alone we're sending 992
testing devices and 450 000
tests to more than 950 nursing homes
across the country
and these tests are incredible these are
tests that are
all new very modern and we're also
getting
on the the tests that are not uh done
these are all new tests as opposed to
the old ones from three months ago
when they do send them to a lab they're
coming back now in three days so it's a
three-day process which is about as good
as you can do
you have one day of delivering one day
of receiving and one day
in the lab we're also requiring all
nursing homes to test all members of
their staff at least weekly
by unleashing america's scientific
genius we have delivered effective
treatments the case
fatality rate for americans over 70 has
declined by about 85 percent that's a
fantastic number it's decline that's
case fatality it's declined by 85
percent
europe has seen 40 percent more excess
mortality than the united states
compared to
a non-pandemic year so
you hear the numbers and those numbers
are
very interesting but that's the way it
is we continue to urge all americans to
wash your hands socially distance wear a
mask when necessary
and when you cannot distance and protect
very importantly the vulnerable protect
people
that are older and especially people
that have problems with heart or
diabetes or some other
problem earlier today very exciting
news very big news all over the world
they're talking about it
all over the world it was amazing we
finalized a historic peace agreement
between israel and the united
arab emirates after half a century
israel and the united arab emirates will
fully normalize their diplomatic
relations nobody thought this was
something that could happen for a long
time this is the most important
diplomatic breakthrough since the
egypt israel peace agreement was signed
over 40 years ago we have ambassador to
israel david friedman here thank you
david for being here we very
much you would agree that this was a big
day for
israel and a big day for the world good
thank you david you've been fantastic
too fantastic ambassador david
and representative of our country thank
you very much
the deal that was reached today will
enable muslims to have
far greater ability to visit many
historic sites in israel
and to peacefully pray at the al-aqsa
mosque
which is very important to them which
they've wanted to have
access to for many many decades
this is a monumental step to forging
ties
of cooperation in the middle east and i
think you're going to have
other countries come forward i can tell
you we already do
and they want to make a deal they could
have peace in the
middle east would be fantastic
israel is also suspending settlements in
the west bank which is a big deal
a bold step toward achieving peace
israel and the united arab emirates have
also agreed to immediately expand and
accelerate
scientific collaboration to develop
effective treatments and vaccines to
defeat the china virus they've both been
hit
virtually every country has been hit 188
countries
and to save lives in their region and in
their world
so they are working very much on the
vaccines also with us and
again some very good news is going to
take place with respect to that
our unprecedented diplomatic engagements
laid the groundwork for this
historic peace agreement which was just
announced a little while ago today
we will not rest as we continue to work
toward a
world of greater harmony and prosperity
for all
i want to thank prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
of israel and crown prince mohammed
bin zayed of the united arab emirates
two fantastic people for their vision
and their leadership and i look forward
to hosting them at the white house very
soon to formally sign the agreement
we'll probably be doing it over the next
i would say three weeks and they'll be
coming
to washington so that was a tremendous
day that was a tremendous thing that
happened
and it's a great sign we have a lot of
other
interesting things going on with other
nations also having to do with peace
agreements
and a lot of big news is coming over the
next few weeks
and i'm sure you'll be very impressed
and more importantly it's a great thing
for our country
great thing for the world when he says
you'll be impressed like is he talking
to the
media is that who he wants to impress
about
school age kids and food one of the real
problems when you shut down the schools
these are kids on reduced and free lunch
programs
they need these meals to make it through
their day
it seems like a sycophantic play here
well what if anything
can the federal government do to make
sure that the kids
still get decent meals as long as the
schools are out
well you know we don't want the schools
shut down we want the schools to open
and especially very young children
handling children all children but
especially very young children handle it
very well
so we want schools open we don't want to
be in that position we want schools
there's no question now
we've made payment and we would frankly
if the school isn't going to open we
would much rather follow the child with
the payment
give the money to the child meaning the
parents of the child
and let that let the parents do what
they have to do
including bringing the child to another
school because we're finding that
whether it's
a crazy idea parents or children people
want to get back to school they want to
have their
life back some people say they don't
want the democrats don't want schools
open because that's where you have a lot
of polling booths
and if you have a school closed you
can't very easily have polling booths at
the school
that's insane the poll workers are
completely different people
that's the first time i've heard such a
ridiculous phrase
talking point that's another thing that
they're doing to try and keep people
away from the polls
so we have to look into that it's
democrats who don't want people voting
right
i've been reading about it and i don't
like it but we'd like to see the schools
open
didn't answer the question we don't have
that problem question was about lunch
what's your understanding of how long
israel will suspend
this west bank annexation plan uh
what do you think tell me
we have we're putting all our eggs into
the basket of peace
we have an agreement with the emirates
we're going to nail down all the details
embassies over flights commercial
then we're going to extrapolate that to
the rest of the region how long that
takes
i i can't tell you but that's we've
prioritized
uh peace over the sovereignty movement
uh but it's not off the table it's just
something that will be deferred until
the uh we give peace every single chance
what do you want the palestinians to
take away from this deal since they're
not really a party to
it well but they are supported largely
by some of the countries that
we're talking to and that have already
signed you know in the case of the one
country but others
will be following this is just like
trump's so clueless there's not even
anything to comment on
without saying it necessarily yet i
think they very much want to be a part
of what we're doing
and i see ultimately the palestinians i
see peace between israel and the
palestinians i see that happening
i think as these very big powerful
wealthy countries come
in i think the palestinians will follow
quite naturally yeah please do you
believe that a deal could be reached
without
israel's agreement to temporarily
temporarily
suspend annexation say it again could
you make it louder
do you believe that the deal could have
been reached without israel's agreement
to temporarily suspend
i don't even know that that question
makes sense david it's interesting
i think you can't do both at the same
time so i think
again prioritize peace sovereignty
uh after peace is given every
opportunity to turn to sovereignty
i don't think the two could have been
done at the same time
have you asked israel to permanently
consider
uh abandoning annexation now this is
this is a temporary process there's been
no request
okay please caitlyn this morning you
said
that you do not want to fund the us
postal service because democrats are
trying to expand
voting by mail so i've got two questions
for you one are you threatening to veto
any legislation that includes
funding for the post post office no not
at all no
so you would sign something that does
include funding a separate thing i would
do it
but one of the reasons the post office
needs that much money is to have all of
these millions of ballots coming in from
nowhere and nobody knows from where and
where they're going is coming in from
nowhere
caitlyn and virginia it was uh you know
500 000 applications coming in going all
over the state nobody even knows where
they came from you saw what happened in
new york which was
a disaster with congresswoman remember
no one's even alleging fraud in new york
maloney it was a it was a basic disaster
and you see paterson new jersey what's
going on there and we can give you many
other locations on sites
what has happened is that's part of a
big negotiation that's a actually small
part of a big negotiation to get
more money to people that it wasn't
their fault it was china's fault
and post office is part of it another
part of it is they want three and a half
billion dollars
just for the ballots himself why it's so
much i don't know but that's what the
democrats want
notice he hasn't asked anyone he just
keeps repeating the same talking point
and that would also mean that the three
and a half billion dollars isn't going
to be taken care of
so i don't know how you could possibly
use these ballots these mail-in ballots
absentee ballots by the way are fine
fine but the universal mailings are just
sent all over the place where people can
grab them and grab stacks of them and
sign them and do whatever you want
that's the thing we're against isn't
that precisely the problem is that
you're saying you do not want to give
this post office funding in this
coronavirus legislation
they say they need it so they can be
prepared the pandemic is still going on
in november when the election happens
and people don't feel safe to go vote in
person they can vote by mail
and it can be safe and it can be
question's two comments i can understand
the post office and if we could agree to
a bill the overall bill
which is obviously a much bigger number
than just the post office that would be
fine but they have the post office as
one of their requests it's their request
you said you were against it didn't you
i'm only against what i'm against
is i'm against doing anything where the
people aren't taken care of and the
people aren't being taken care of
properly
we have we want people to get money it
wasn't their fault that they got shut
down they got shut down by china
so whether it's we want the people to
get money so that they vote for me not
to make it easier to vote if they might
vote for the other guy
and a half billion dollars just for the
universal male imbalance
but they're not willing to make a deal
these are two points within a very big
deal
the thing they want more than anything
else caitlyn and you know this is
bailout money for the states and for the
cities that are in trouble
which for the most part a democrat run
states and cities so
new york has a problem california has a
problem uh illinois has a tremendous
problem
and other states they want to be able to
bail out these states and we don't want
to be
doing that or certainly don't want to do
it to the extent they're looking for one
trillion dollars
we don't want to be doing that please go
ahead i'm just really confused because
you said they need that money in order
to make the post office work so it can
take all these millions and millions of
ballots
and you said that would be fraudulent so
it sounded like you said no i said it
will end up being fraudulent because
if you look at what's happening over the
last few weeks just look at the few
instances where this has happened it's
turned out to be fraudulent
well if you look at new york it was
fraudulent if you look at paterson new
jersey it was for origin
of course there is the the whole thing
is a mess in fact carolyn maloney's
opponent is he's gone crazed he said
they took the election away from him
and he may be right i think they should
redo that election
and if you look at virginia it's
terrible look at some of the things that
have happened
in california look at california where
they found
a million non-eligible voters that was
done by judicial watch
tom fitton and judicial ones completely
bomb through we have to have an honest
election
and if it's not going to be an honest
election i guess people have to sit down
and
think really long and hard about it but
if the post office if they're not going
to approve a bill
and the post office therefore won't have
the money and if they're not going to
approve
a big bill a bigger bill and they're not
going to have the three and a half
billion dollars for the universal
mail-in votes he's going to have to go
to oan next vote
what would mean is the people have to go
to the polls and vote
like the old days like two years ago
three years ago four years ago
they have to go to the it doesn't say
anybody's taking the vote
away but it means that the universal
mail-ins don't work absentees do work
it's a very different thing an absentee
where you make an application and you
send it in they send you a vote it's
different
but so caitlyn i'm not saying anything
wrong with
voting i want them to vote but that
would mean that they'd have to go to a
voting booth like they used to and vote
even if they don't feel safe
voting in person people want to vote by
mail because well they're going to have
to feel safe and they will be safe and
we will make sure that they're safe
and we're not going to have to spend
three and a half billion dollars to do
it
and when you go to a voting it would be
wonderful if we had voting id and some
states have that and so when i go to
stone because they can't get it passed
most states want it but we want people
to vote
but we want people to vote so when they
vote it means one vote it doesn't mean
ballots all over the place you saw what
would what was happening
in virginia where in winter i walk
around with a big puffy coat just
stuffed full of ballots
they had them named after dogs they had
them named after dead people
dogs we want to have an accurate vote
i'm not doing this for any reason maybe
the other turns out to be my advantage i
don't know i can't tell you that
but i do know this i just want an
accurate vote
and it's a fair question by the way so
does everybody else
okay mr president how does the
accord today between israel and the uae
uh helped struggling and persecuted
christians in the middle east
help what how does it help struggling in
person he was looking at caitlyn collins
and signaling something to her that was
bizarre all right and
you're right about that christians have
been persecuted by some
countries in particular in the middle
east and i think this is a big start
it's going to be a very strong start
very powerful start
and it's something that i will tell you
i've told david and i've told every one
of our negotiators
if you look at the way christians have
been treated in some countries it's
it's beyond disgraceful it's
uh if i if i
had information and if i had
absolute proof some of the stories that
we've heard which are not easy which is
not easy to get start bombing people i
would go in and do a number to those
countries
like you wouldn't believe yeah what they
do to christians
and it's it's disgraceful it's
disgraceful you're right
it's a very big part of the overall
negotiation and as countries come in
for instance uae has agreed very
strongly to
represent us i think they will very well
with respect to
what christianity because in the middle
east it's not treated well
it's not treated well at all it's
treated horribly and very unfairly and
uh it's criminal what's happened
what and that's for many many years i
think it's a great question and very
it's a very unfair situation please
thank you mr president
larry kudlow said that there is a
routine check-in call with uh
china on the phase one trade deal my
question is
what if they bring up tick-tock and and
also wechat
would you engage would you instruct your
team to engage them on that example
we have a deadline of september 15th and
whether it's microsoft i understand and
others are negotiating
we also said that obviously it's
worthless if we don't allow them into
the country so we said that the united
states treasury is going to be
getting something out of this deal
something very substantial
but what we want is total security but
we have a deadline of september 15th
so i know microsoft and others are very
interested in it
but that's our deadline and it has to be
proven to be totally secure
we don't want to have any information
going into china
with what we've been through and i have
to tell you talked about the deal you
mentioned
the phase one deal well the phase one
deal
uh it's very interesting situation
because you've been hearing
the largest order of corn in history the
largest order of soybeans the largest
order of beef
they've done more than they've ever done
so you're gonna have to figure that one
out with
where i'm coming from i could have
because they see my attitude
my attitude toward china is not friendly
he needs an attitudinal adjustment
gone into orders that are extremely
large extremely large
and our farmers are very happy but
with what they did with respect to the
pandemic not what i'm hearing the uh
the plague that came in from china uh
it just is a different feeling it was an
incredible deal
but i have a very different feeling but
they are giving they are giving
the midwest our farmers among the
largest orders they've ever seen
somebody told me today bob lighthouse
that it's about 40 percent of the
of what they're selling now is uh going
to china
so maybe they're trying to make me
change my mind a little bit what because
you know my attitude
on china and it's not it hasn't been
very good
well we're not talking to them no we're
talking to the companies
theory it's a company but it's a company
within china that means china
and uh the deal will have to be
substantially beneficial to the united
states not everything is
okay can you
say whether you yourself think that
annexation should be off the table for
israel and if so have you communicated
that
so not off the table i know it's
something they've discussed but
uh israel has agreed not to do that i
mean more than just
off the table they've agreed not to do
it and i think that was
very important and i think it was a
great concession
by israel and i think it was a very
smart concession by israel
but uh david you have anything further
prime minister was
was pretty clear today at his own press
conference that he considers this to be
a temporary suspension
and that the deal would still be open to
him at some point in the future
i'm asking what you think he should do
well right now all i can say
it's off the table so i can't talk about
sometime into the future
but it's not it's what he seems very
confused is that a correct statement mr
ambassador yes the word suspend was
chosen carefully by all the parties
suspended by definition uh look it up
that means temporary halt
uh it's off the table down but it's not
off the table per hour
go ahead just to follow the questions
that caitlin was asking
you said you do want an accurate vote
direct the postmaster general
to reverse some of the policy changes
that have occurred there in order to
prevent delays
no i wouldn't do that at all no i want
the post office to run properly
but which makes sense they would need a
lot more money if they're going to be
taking in
tens of millions of ballots that just
come out of the sky from nowhere
and so that's actually not true the post
office could have handled the ballots no
problem the post office handles a crazy
number of ballot of pieces of mail
if you kneecap them then you might cause
a problem states that are
run by governors who happen to be
democrats who have not done a good job
for many many years
and those estates that owe a lot of
money and need a lot of money and
they're talking about
one trillion dollars so the post office
and the
three and a half billion dollars for the
votes themselves which sounds like a lot
of money they're looking for three and a
half billion dollars think of that three
and a half billion dollars to have
mail-in ballots uh again absentee good
universal mailing very bad
[Applause]
one quick follow-up given that the
negotiations are still ongoing about
whether to get more money
to the postal service why not put more
resources and more money yourself
find a way to do that to make sure there
isn't well they can do it very easily
all they have to do is make a deal
if they make a deal the postal service
is taken care of
the money they need for the mail-in
ballots would be taken care of if we
agree to it that doesn't mean we're
going to agree to it
but all they have to do is make a deal
but again more important to them
is not that that's a lot of money but
it's small time compared to the other
what they want to do and very very very
strongly what they want to do is bail
out cities that are run by
democrats and have been for many years
and these cities and states have done
very badly and they desperately need
money for that
and we're open to something but we're
not open to the kind of money that they
need go ahead please
mr president three and a half years just
one second please what are you doing as
president to make sure there is a free
and fair election
is it what what are you doing as
president to make sure there is a free
and fair way so
everyone talks about russia russia
russia they talk about
china china they talk about all of these
different countries that come in and run
our elections which is false but what
they do
what they don't talk about are things
like very loose
mail-in ballots universal
in nature that frankly russia
china north korea iran
all of these countries that we are
reading about hearing about and in some
cases they're writing about
intelligence-wise
these countries can grab those ballots
or print
forgeries of those ballots and they
would go out and they would have a field
day this is a little secret they could
do it with an absentee ballot too
which he says is fine a country like a
china or a russia
or a north korea or iran i hear
ran too you know that was part of the
report
this would be very easy for them this is
much easier than
well we have been very strong now if you
remember president obama was informed
about russia by the fbi in september
the election was in november president
obama decided to do
absolutely nothing about it people don't
mention that very much anymore that's a
lost fact
but he was informed very powerfully that
they're going to do and president obama
did nothing
we have done a lot and we've really
shored it up but what people can never
prepare for
are millions and millions of mail-in
ballots
because they can be forged they can be
captured they can be taken
no well that's a very hard thing to do
we have to make sure that we can do that
please mr president after three and a
half years
you regretted all all the lying you've
done to the american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who is done
you have done oh man tensorflow go ahead
please
oh boy go ahead
i wanted to ask about the payroll packs
cut
one uh is it to be optional or mandatory
for
employers um to oh my god
and not collect the payroll taxes
the payroll tax is very important and a
very big
benefit guys i'm how who is that guy and
how did he get in there and will he ever
be allowed back
strong but now directly to people and
it's a very big number
and we're taking care of it this will go
directly to the people
the workers within the company it's a
payroll tax it's called the payroll
tax cut we're cutting the payroll tax
and it's a very large number and that
will go that was legendary it really was
nobody
employers collect that through fico will
that be suspect
are they gonna be required not to
collect that money
you mean later on you mean later on at
all so september 1 when i get my
paycheck
will the employers the employers will
collect it and give it
most likely the employers will collect
trump seems rattled by that huh
please go ahead i have to question the
first one on domestic politicians
can't understand the words she's
circulating in social media that
karma harris is not eligible to be to
run for vice president because she was
an anchor baby i hope
do you or can you definitively say
whether or not pamela harris
is eligible legally meets the legal
requirements to run as vice president
so i just heard that i heard it today
this is the new birtherism meet the
requirements uh
and by the way the lawyer that wrote
that piece is a very highly qualified
very talented
lawyer from a pro-trump think tank
i would have assumed the democrats would
have checked that out before she gets
chosen to run for vice president this is
the new birtherism guys
seriously you're saying that they're
saying that she doesn't qualify because
she wasn't born in this country she was
born she was born in this country but
her parents
did not the claims say that her parents
did not receive their permanent
residence
not even the assertion this is so
idiotic uh that's not even what's being
claimed and what's being claimed is
wrong i mean this is
ten layers off that you or she's hoping
that you might be able to deliver the
speech in front of the u.n general
assembly in person
even though other leaders will be
sending in their video recordings
can you confirm that yeah i'm thinking
about going directly to the u.n to do
the speech
a lot of people will not because of
kovid will not be able to be there
uh as you know but i'm thinking i think
it's
appropriate if we can do it i'll do it
directly and
again this will not be like in the past
because some countries won't be able to
escape the problems they're having you
know countries are having a tremendous
problem with
the china virus so we'll see what
happens but
i would prefer doing it i can do it the
other way i can do it
uh viral as they say i can do it in that
form but i'd rather be at the united
nations
viral i think it's i think it better
represents the country
also i feel sort of a at least a semi
obligation as
the president of the united states to be
at the united nations to deliver what
will be an important speech
well the room won't be empty the room
will have different people there and
representatives
of countries but i can understand how
it's you know it's very difficult for
countries to be there
they won't be there only for that reason
they'd love to be there i've already had
people call in fact say a couple of them
i'd love to be there if you want i'll be
there i said don't be there
you don't have to be there no the room
would be
i think the room will not be although
there may be a spacing requirement like
you have in this room
this room was always packed this room
would be packed again if we had the
seats open but you have a spacing
requirement so i understand that the
united nations they may have that too
yes please thank you mr president i have
a question on the piece deal but if you
don't mind
can i refer my question to you from epic
times
sure oh my god epic times is in there
now
thank you i would like to ask your
opinion about
what recently happened in hong kong
recent attack on
uh press freedom in hong kong and jimmy
was arrested his newsroom was raided
how will the u.s respond to this well i
think it's a terrible thing but one
thing that we have was that oan
deferring to epic times how is epic
times even in there
because of freedom that's epoch by the
way
we were giving tremendous economic
incentives to hong kong
and we have now withdrawn all of those
incentives and it will be impossible for
hong kong to compete
with the united states with respect to
that it just won't be
because we've taken all of the
incentives away if you look at china
with the world trade organization as an
example
they're getting tremendous because
they're considered a developing nation
which is ridiculous why should they be a
developing nation but we're not
and they get tremendous incentives we
have by the way uh
told them it's unacceptable and we've
been we've been
doing that for a long time they
understand exactly how we feel yeah
big changes are being made but with
respect to hong kong they get tremendous
financial incentives
so that they could do business and
compete in the world
we've now withdrawn all of those
incentives it's going to be very hard
for hong kong to compete
and i will tell you that the united
states and
i say this from any standpoint you want
to hear it will end up making a lot more
money because of it because we lost a
lot of business to hong kong
we made it very convenient for people to
go there for companies to go there
we've withdrawn all of that and the
united states will be a big beneficiary
from an economic standpoint
but i hate to see what happened to hong
kong because freedom is a great thing
thank you all very much thank you thank
you very much
well it's another completely delusional
press briefing in the books once again
and
a lot of confusing and bizarre
statements certainly made
and the hero of course let's see if we
can go back to it let me see if i can
find
where was that guy who asked the
question
where was this guy let's see
was it this guy oh here it is yep let
here you guys are going to like this
let's go back to it i want to hear it we
have to make sure that we can do that
please uh mr president after three and a
half years
you regretted all all the lying you've
done to the american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who has done
you have done uh tensorflow
oh man arguably the best moment right i
mean that's
i can't i don't know that there's been a
better moment during any of these
coronavirus
press it's legendary it's legendary and
let me go back
i just want to get another just brief
look at that guy
um where is this guy because they can be
forged
they can be captured they can be taken
no well that's a very hard thing to do
we have to make sure that we can do that
please mr president after three and a
half years
you regretted all all the lying you've
done to the american people
check this this guy some this guy's
aesthetic is on
point um i have no no clue who that is
but maybe somebody can figure it out
and in fact if anybody if anybody is
able to if anybody's tweeted out this
video like maybe actually let's see if
aaron rupar has
twitter.com let's see if aaron grabbed
it because this is just
amazing um
oh yep here it is beautiful we're i'm
just going to retweet this right now
before we go any further
because this is just tremendous um
ask trump after three yep here it is
anybody know who this hero reporter
is most compelling moment
of any coronavirus press briefing
thus far uh what a moment
what am i what the hell new message no
that's not what i want oh it disappeared
all right well i guess i'm gonna have to
deal with that later no problem
whatsoever
uh okay if you're heading out please
remember
on youtube please hit that subscribe
button
we could get to 940 000 subscribers
instantly we're only 700 away okay
help us to a million help us to 940.
um 20 000 people watching right now
please hit that subscribe button
of course if you are watching over on
twitch we are approaching 50
000 followers i would very much
appreciate
uh the follow there as well thanks to
everybody who signed up
super chatted all of that stuff i will
talk to everybody again
very very soon
you